[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: We are definitely
witnessing a phase change,
a turning point in
America's relationship
with cannabis sativa.
That's right, the
marijuana plant,
a sacrament that's been
used for thousands of years,
in all kinds of contexts,
for promoting healing,
for promoting transformation,
for promoting spirituality.
And every day we're learning
a host of new benefits
that are associated
with the plant.
Now, I think it's kind
of amazing, not just
for the fact that this
plant is nontoxic, and has
so many medicinal and
therapeutic benefits,
but also for the fact
as a sacred sacrament,
this raises the issue
of cognitive liberty,
the fact that as adults, if
we're not hurting anybody else,
we should have the
right to explore
the contours of our
own consciousness
without any mediation
or legislation
on the part of somebody else.
Prohibition, as Abraham
Lincoln used to say,
goes beyond the
bounds of reason,
and attempts to legislate
a man's appetite
by making a crime of
things that are not crimes.
I'm paraphrasing, but
you get the point.
But I think now the
majority of Americans
support marijuana legalization.
We're seeing more and more
states embrace this issue
of cognitive freedom.
And I think we're going
to see transformation
in consciousness.
Not to mention that
marijuana is extraordinarily
sensitive to initial
rhetorical conditions.
It's what Timothy Leary used
to describe as set and setting.
So by changing the
context, by changing
the culture in which people
partake in this visionary herb,
you're changing the very nature
of the medicine's effects.
Experiments in Colorado are
raising the stage in which
people enjoy their cannabis.
We're talking
culinary experiences,
we're talking classical
music venues and concerts.
We're talking special cinemas
with vaporizing rooms, where
people can prime their
brains for enhanced cinematic
diversion.
It's a new world,
and it's a world
that it's going to be
interesting to see how it all
unfolds.
Cognitive thrills await us
that we cannot even imagine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]